in this video we'll talk about
ionotropic receptors
ionotropic receptors are generally
ligand-gated ion channels
that means in a ligand-bound state
they would conduct ions across these
channels
in our nervous system there are two
types of receptors
ionotropic receptors and metabotropic
receptors
ionotropic receptors are ligand-gated
ion channel while metabotropic receptors
are generally g-protein-coupled
receptors
they synthesize metabolites which lead
to intracellular changes
now in this video we'll focus on
ionotropic receptors and not on
metabotropic receptors but if you want a
video on metabotropic receptors link
would be found in the i button
generally ionotropic receptors are
ligand-gated ion channel where the ion
channel is made up of three four or five
subunits
these subunits are generally
diverse they could be heteromar or
homomar
anyway it has a ligand binding pocket
where the ligand binds
upon binding to the ligand
there could be
conformational change
and the transmembrane domain has the
selectivity folder
or selectivity pocket for the ions
now let us look at the functioning
property in bit more details
so in a ligand unbound state they would
be inactive and the gate would be closed
in a ligand bound state the gate would
be open and the ion channel is
conductive
so whenever there is a presence of
ligand
the gate would be
open and in this case you can see the
gate is closed
but upon binding to specific ligands
the gate will open right now and the
ions can pass across this channel
and this is how the ligand-gated ion
channel or ionotropic receptors work
question is where we can find this
ionotropic receptor and the simple
answer is our central nervous system in
the central nervous system we can find
them in all the glutamatergic synapses
in the post synapse of glutamatergic
synapse we can see these kind of metabo
this kind of ionotropic receptors all
the glutamate receptors
are divided into two groups ionotropic
and metabotropic the ionotropic
receptors are pretty common all across
the nervous system
other than that we can find them in
neuromuscular junction stomach in many
other locations as well let's say in the
stomach we can find them in the parietal
cells now let's focus on our
glutamatergic synapse to understand how
they work
now in the glutamatergic synapse when a
presynaptic action potential arrive then
arrive at the nerve terminal it leads to
the release of neurotransmitters shown
here in pink
these neurotransmitters work like a
ligand for the postsynaptic channels
they bind to the postsynaptic channel
open the postsynaptic channel and
thereby
many cations can
get inside of the postsynapse cationic
influx leads to a positive change in the
membrane voltage which leads to an
increase
of the potential towards the positive
side this generates the postsynaptic
potential
now ionotropic glutamate receptors are
pretty common they are generally
ligand-gated sodium channels so they
allow sodium ion to come in
it's important to notice that there are
ionotropic gaba receptors as well
which are ligand-gated
chloride channels which lead to a
intrusion of chloride or negative ion
inside the neurons and lead to our
inactivation of these neurons
now ionotropic acetylcholine receptors
are also very common in the
neuromuscular junction along with the
glutamatergic system glutamatergic
receptors
so if we zoom into a neuromuscular
junction we can see all these
nicotinic acetylcholine receptors which
upon binding to acetylcholine can allow
influx of cation into the muscle and
thereby depolarizing the muscle
so now in this video we talked about
ionotropic receptors and where we can
find them how they work
let me tell you that ionotropic
receptors are fast response receptors
that means the overall response of
ionotropic receptors are quite fast
compared to a metabotropic receptors if
you want to find more about ionotropic
and metabotropic receptors the video
would be in the i button
anyway you can get many more videos and
notes
in my facebook channel you can get
annotated flash cards
small tricks mnemonics all of these are
available in my instagram page links are
provided in the description
you can support me in patreon also there
is a super thanks option
after every video you can find it in the
bottom right corner of the video
you can pay me via paypal paytm and upi
anyway you can follow me on social media
and my all social media links are
provided in the description also our
partner channel nerdmedic follow that
all the descript all the social media
links are provided in the description